as I was doing research for purposes of
my videos I came up to one article that
includes 20 pages of detailed outline
for the seventh episode before I
introduced with his detailed outline for
the season finale let me just say that
beside those 20 pages regarding the
seventh episode there was also detailed
outline of every episode of the season
which pro to be quite accurate if you
don't want anything spoiled it's time
for you to close this video episode
starts at the Lannister armies being
deployed in force around and on the city
walls
Bronn finishes overseeing their
placement from the battlements he looks
out upon several thousands unsullied
troops commanded by grey worm arrayed in
perfect formation a few hundred yards
away bran moves along the battlements to
join Janie Brown reveals that when it
comes to siege preparations he prefers
being on the offensive side of things
Jamie hopes it will not come to an
actual siege for all their sakes
together they watch from the walls as
the track horde break the horizon and
convert someone said eight ten thousand
screamer strong did the track he poured
through the gaps in the unsullied
formations their passage does not cause
a single and solid flinch though the
track you present their customary show
of strength before the city votes
Brandon insides he really doesn't want
to see Jeter then his flagship sails
into Blackwater Bay with her fleet the
nurse is not on her flagship but her
whole team and her allies are John
d'aagh Styrian Jorah varies from sandy
theone they approach the flagships
islands resting at the head of urine
graders Fleet urine has cordoned of the
mouth of the black water using a heavy
thick chain then his ships cannot pass
unless he lets them thean looks nervous
let his uncle's fleet wondering out loud
when Denny is coming Jorah promises him
shall be there stating that she said
she'd be here and then he does what she
says Jon and Tyrion watch the
approaching City one is a returning
Exile and the other has never been to
the capital in his life or any large
city for that matter John asks how many
people live here
tyrion replies a million give or take
John tries to get his head around the
notion of a million people in one place
and why anyone would want to live that
way the food during offers then he
continues and the brothels both far
superior but I doubt we'll be here for
long enough to taste much of the former
and I will guess you're not interested
in tasting the latter so your experience
of
capital will largely be limited to my
family by the time we're done you'll be
very happy to get back to the White
Walkers in a quarter beloved eggs the
Hound approaches a closed door he stands
in front of it and listens to the
silence he taps on the door once quietly
a barrage of thumping and snarling
explodes from the behind the door
satisfied that their precious cargo is
undead and well the Hound walks away the
foundry merge sundeck joining the others
then his flagship stops as it approaches
silence yeren steps onto the deck of his
ship and looks at them for a tense
moment then he gives a word to his
captain who lays to it to the rest of
the fleet the chain drops alarming
Danish ship to pass through as they pass
the ships come so close to each other
urines polite right this way gesture
gives john and company pause young give
special smile to Theon
Cersei prepares her summit with Qyburn
the son is nearing its peak the
appointed time has almost arrived
Cersei asks if anyone has seen the news
yet and Qyburn replies with no not yet
mahjongg snow Tyrion all of Danish
trusted allies and advisors are on their
way to the dragon pit they discussed a
scenario of mutually assured destruction
if Cersei were to harm Daini or her
advisors in any way her dragons can lay
waste to all of them and once they're
all in the dragon pit it then he tries
to inflict the death from above
sir Gregor has his orders he will
immediately execute the Dragon Queen's
entire command structure
beginning with Dany herself Qyburn is
duty-bound to point out that a third
outliner option reaming for the dragon
queen
Qyburn says the nurse could not go to
the dragon pit at all flying with her
dragons and kill everyone inside the
dragon pit allies and enemies alike
which would leave Danny the only power
left in the game Circe is confident this
will not happen
Cersei states that then is the breaker
of chains the queen of marine who
liberated slavers Bay
she may rule three huge beasts and
hordes of foreign savages and eunuchs
but she's a slave to the titles she has
bestowed upon herself and the legend
they perpetuate without them she is
nothing but an invader and faces it
invaders people always fall back on the
rulers they know people don't remember
those rulers were invaders themselves
not so long ago because people are sheep
with tiny sheep brains with the mountain
and the Queen's Guard in tow serfs in
Qyburn head off to the dragon pit the
dragon pits bronze main doors with
dragon reliefs
have been sealed for hundreds of years
and now Lannister troops are opening
them again for Tyrion Jon and company
who approached on the main road then he
is still not here
the hound brings up the rear of the
procession walking alongside the covered
wagon bran meets them at the door on the
way to the covered backstage colonnade
the area to the main floor bran and
Tyrion speak they made this happen maybe
it will even work bran sincerely hopes
so and also says by my reckoning between
you and your brother I'm on the castle
and wife for every day of the week don't
think I'm likely to collect if you
murder each other
Tyrion then asks if Sir sees here and
bran replies she is bran asks after
Danny interior implies she's coming
bran recounts seeing Danny and says
quite a woman almost turned Jamie into
charcoal Tyrion tries to tell bran that
then is the best chance they have to
make the next hundred years different
from the last hundred which leaves bran
surprised Brandt says she was nice to
look at though from what I could make
out while she was roasting us alive
Branagh's asks Tyrion if he has any luck
with her Tyrion's expression protests
but Brandt says don't pretend with me I
know what you like Brown looks over his
shoulder at Jon Snow and says handsome
brother and asks Tyrion if the dragon
Queen has any intimate relationships
with him bran says his what they go for
him and your brother not us we're never
the one they go for we're the other one
bran catches sight of Jorah tyrion tells
Brown who he is reminding him that
George started out informing on Danny
for Robert on which bran replies with
and now he's just like you soon shall
have a whole string of you following her
around like baby ducks they merge into
the center of the dragon pit Cersei has
not made any big preparations just the
appropriate number of chairs grouped
according to allegiance arrayed in a
circle in the centre of dragon pit Circe
is already waiting sitting with Jaime
Qyburn urine and the mountain and the
entirety of her Queen's Guard John and
Davos find their way to their own space
a semicircle of chairs of eight Dana's
loyalists but deigning herself is still
nowhere to be seen when Cersei realizes
this she's not happy since she does not
like to wait for someone Circe is
preparing to leave when the news arrives
on jog on meat regal in tow the crumbled
edge of the pit crumbles further when
dragon sets down then he climbs down his
wing and makes her way towards the main
floor Jordan takes off to the air again
to join his brother the two of
memorizing injurers to the scheie
overhead but the whole time remaining in
sight
most are cowed by the sight of these
beasts but Circe is not all she displays
is this Dane for theatricality of the
gesture as then he takes her seat
opposite Circe in circle Brown gives
Tyrion a parting piece of advice you're
better off not wanting a girl like that
girl like this is not manageable Circe
then says shall we begin
some of us have been here for some time
and then is prompting tearing is about
to begin but before he can make it to
the center of the circle to kick things
off irin stands up and says I'll start
young calls Elfie and publicly he gets
the in sister alive and he threatens to
kill the RA thean does not submit to him
here and now
Tyrion looks the Jaime like who this guy
think is and from Jaime's expression
Tyrion sees that Jamie is nothing good
relations with the Lancers only alive I
think we ought to begin with larger
concerns Tyrion says only Tyrion replies
with then why are you talking urine
makes a casual threat to Tyrion bran
comes a bit closer to the circle ready
to kill the Ironborn if he has to
Cersei shuts them all up Tyrion says as
this recent display has shown this is a
group of people who do not like each
other they have suffered tragedies at
each other hands they have lost people
at each other's hands if all each party
wanted was more of the same there would
be no need for this summit they're more
than capable of waging war against each
other without meeting face to face
Cersei replies with so instead we're
going to settle our differences once and
for all and live together in harmony for
the rest of our days John takes the
floor and says we all know that will
never happen and continues with this
isn't about that this is about what's
coming for all of us a general you can
talk to and can't reason with an army
you can't kill because they are already
dead and when they fight man they don't
leave corpses on the battlefield Lord
Tyrion tells me a million people live in
this city
they're about to become a million more
soldiers in the army of the Dead Cersei
then says for most of them I imagine it
would be an improvement
Jen replies with I've seen them this is
serious I would not be here speaking to
you if it wasn't I don't think it's
serious at all I think it's a joke
Cersei says and continues if my brother
has informed me correctly you're asking
me to send a Lannister armies all the
way north how convenient would that be
for you if I went on a big grump King
hunt and let the capital my capital
unprotected all on the word of a
would-be usurper the use of that fur
Neela's said Danny off material calms
her down clearly the time for talking
has ended he signals for the hound with
the captive white to be brought into the
dragon pit the count steps into the
dragon pit and he sees his brother
behind the Queen upon bringing a
Hampshire white to the center he
releases it so everyone could see for
themselves that the threat is real the
white sees Cersei first and charges even
though the mountain steps in front of
Cersei and jabs his sword ready to slice
the thing in two there is no need for a
fight since the Hound has the white
chained and he simply pulls it to the
ground the white then comes for the
hound who drops his sword and cuts the
white in half its legs continue kicking
and its torso keeps coming for the Hound
the demonstration has desired effect on
Cersei shaking her in a way few things
can everyone else who has never seen one
of these things as shocked as well
except for Qyburn who picks up the still
moving hand and beholds it with
fascination we can destroy them by
burning them John says and uses a torch
to burn the disembodied pieces of the
white including the hand he takes from
the Qyburn and we can destroy them with
dragonglass John continues and draws a
dragonglass dagger John says if we don't
win this fight that pointing to the
white stores as it crawls towards him
with its single arm is the fate of every
person in the world man the white horse
reaches him his tab said with the dragon
glass ending the demonstration okay guys
this would be the first part while the
second half is currently in the process
and will be released as soon as possible
make sure you stay tuned for the second
part because it's by far more exciting
than the first half